what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and lately we've been
getting a whole bunch of questions and
comments about updates for code geass
season 3 we've been getting so many
questions on this topic that I can't
even keep up with all of them so I
decided to just make a quick video to
let you know about all the latest
updates about code geass season 3 now we
do have some interesting news and
updates but we still don't have an
official release date for either to
recap movies or for code geass season 3
now of course I wish we did we've been
following not only the english-language
anime news media but also the Japanese
media we've been looking at the official
Code Geass Japanese website every day
we'd be looking at the official Japanese
Twitter for Code Geass but there is
still no official release date for
either the film's or for the actual
sequel however as soon as we get some
big news about the release dates we're
going to go alive on this channel that
video is going to be called Code Geass
breaking news so be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell because
as soon as we know something we're not
going to bother editing a video you know
waiting hours for it to come out we're
going to go alive right away so you can
be the first to know everything that we
know now what we do know is that there's
an insane amount of hype growing for
code VI season 3 in Japan and all over
the world there is a whole bunch of new
merchandise being sold on the official
Code Geass website and there is also a
special anniversary event blu-ray
package that is going to be released on
April 21st in Japan and many are
speculating that this anniversary
package is going to include exclusive
hints and clues for Code Geass season 3
so everyone is really looking forward to
seeing what is in this special package
on top of that crunchyroll news recently
ran an article about the Code Geass
deluxe archives which is a new package
that has become available for fans it is
now available for pre-order and it's
going to include a bunch of different
art books exclusive art from Code Geass
and a lot of people are excited for that
they want to see if the art is going to
include any hints about season 3 but
here's one thing that we caught that is
potentially really important you'll see
that on the actual crunchyroll article
they are reporting that a reprint of the
episode 1 of Code Geass script is going
to be inside of this pack
but look at this page on the official
Japanese website for Cordia so this is
Geass JP if you scroll down you will see
that the script that will be released is
not episode 1 as crunchyroll reported
but a script of the final episode of the
series episode 25 of r2 now this is a
way bigger deal than on episode 1 script
because here you will get to actually
see how they describe the final scenes
of the show how they describe the cart
driver for example and we will see if
they actually give us any sort of hint
about what happens to Lelouch at the end
big thanks to know digit for helping me
find this info now this website is
originally in Japanese and I'm using the
Google Chrome translator to get the
English translation but if you look at
the original Japanese you will see that
what is written here is r2 and the
number 25 so episode 25 of r2 so crunchy
rolls reporting is clearly wrong here
and of course this package is now
available for pre-order until February
17th in Japan so we're going to see I
look forward to seeing if this season 25
script gives us any exclusive clues
about what the creator's intended to
happen at the end of season 2 and what
they intended to happen to Lelouch so
yeah there is a lot of Code Geass
merchandise being sold right now
including new shirts new code geass
themed jewelry a whole bunch of
different art books and things like that
so yeah definitely a lot of hype and by
the way crunchyroll if you need a skills
research team to help you double check
your articles
we are definitely available contact us
here at anime out for the final update
that i want to share with you guys are
these rumors that have been going around
lately on websites like Reddit and my
anime list forums that are essentially
claiming that the PV the teaser trailer
from the anniversary event of Code Geass
back in November that was leaked to
YouTube is actually incomplete these
rumors are claiming that those who
actually attended the event saw extra
scenes with very important stuff
happening in those scenes including
they're claiming that they saw Lelouch
with blue Geass in one eye so the you
know the internet has been going crazy
about these rumors however we can't
confirm any of it until we actually see
the video or have some
who can confirm that they were there
they have a ticket of the event saying
that this is what they saw we can't
confirm it they are just rumors however
if this Blue Geass stuff is interesting
to you I did address my theory as to why
Lelouch could potentially have blue
Geass in our latest what is blue Geass
code vs video so if you want to check
that out you can check the link in the
description so those are all the updates
that we have right now so we have new
merchandise the announcement at an
episode 25 of our two final episodes
script is going to be released and of
course these rumors about an extended PD
unfortunately still no specific news
about the actual release date however if
you subscribe to this channel and click
the notification bell we will go live
it's literally know something and you
will be the first to know and if you
want to stay in the loop on a daily
basis and be a part of our research team
you can join our discord server the link
is in the description as always thank
you so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]